blimps slower than an airplane not very
maneuverable and a bit on the bulky side
a relic of the past right
well not for everyone my name is eager
to push to the lock and I make blimps
that's right blimps and Igor has been
chasing this very specific dream for a
long time I was probably 10 12 years old
when read the book for kids and they
were story about airships both the
blimps become excited I was really
inspirational
Igor studied engineering in university
but starting a blimp empire in the final
throes of the Soviet Union proved
challenging character America was this
group of the young kids suitcase full of
technical books in their ass not speak
English he was really really lucky we
find the first customers pretty fast
wasn't six eight months back there we
start with something very very simple
advertising
an eCourse blimp empire grew from there
eventually selling surveillance blimps
to governments around the world and to
be clear these state-of-the-art airships
are nothing like the blimps from the
Hindenburg days it's almost like compare
the Space Shuttle was genius rocket but
in the back of his mind
there was another goal to create
something the world has never seen
before
a cargo airship is brought with about
900 feet long it's about 300 bones of
the cargo that's three football fields
long just to put it in perspective and
iwere believes a massive floating cargo
ship could come in very handy in a
catastrophe as seen here in his own
artistic rendering Katrina or agent
disaster when humans lived apparent on
some stuff coming kill we can simply
bring this help if this cargo ship
exists we can save a lot of human lives
and he says he's getting really close to
realizing that dream but even when his
airship takes to the sky you or won't
stop I love the process of the building
the airships I cannot stop every day is
more fun than yesterday